let me take you through the numbers
first of all we've had these figures in
the last few minutes from money facts
the data provider the average rate on a
two-year fixed rate mortgage has gone up
from 5.98 on Friday to 6.01 this morning
the average rate on a five-year fixed
rate deal has gone up from 5.62 on the
Friday afternoon to uh 5.67 this morning
meanwhile the number of overall products
available on the mortgage Market has
slipped from
4923 on Friday to 4
683 today meanwhile the average rate on
the two-year buy to let mortgage well
that's gone up from 6.21 on Friday to
6.3 percent now now you mentioned the
people involved who will be affected by
this Jane well we're put we're talking
about uh 400 000 householders whose
mortgage deals are due to expire between
July and September this year that is an
unusually high number so potentially 400
thousand households are going to be
affected by this latest move and the
reason though that the number is so high
you have to cast your mind back to what
was going on in 2021 obviously the
government uh back then uh either cut
stamp duty to near zero or froze it at
lower levels uh to try and stimulate the
housing market during the uh backwash of
the pandemic and uh that meant a lot of
people fixed on a two-year deal at that
time and those deals are now starting to
unwind which is why you've got as I say
such an unusually high number of people
affected right now some four hundred
thousand that's to say potentially on a
typical mortgage you're looking at
around about uh another several hundred
pounds on your mortgage uh payments each
month at this rate
it's terrifying isn't it Ian thanks very
much well let's bring in our political
correspondent tomorrow Cohen who's here
and tomorrow
both the Prime Minister and Richard and
prime minister and also secure stalma at
the opposition have been asked this
morning about mortgages and what they're
going to do to help and neither of them
have a
specific plan to help people actually
directly there isn't going to be a
relief scheme coming perhaps everything
that happened during the covid pandemic
and the fact that people have had Direct
help with their energy bills over the
last year has made people think that the
government will intervene when these
spikes happen but the clear message I'm
getting from treasury sources this
morning is that it's not workable they
don't believe to give people direct help
to pay their mortgages they say the best
way to try and get them under control is
to reduce inflation which is what
they're trying to do this year and they
fear that borrowing money to give to
people to pay their mortgages might
actually Stoke inflation and it might be
bad economics and bad politics because
they suggest that it would help people
who are homeowners potentially at the
higher end of the income scale although
of course people who are renting from
landlords may end up benefiting as well
but it's they say it's not going to
happen it's self-defeating they say as
it might Stoke inflation and labor who
have asked a lot of questions about this
and try to blame the government for the
high interest rates we're seeing saying
it's a result of list truss's mini
budget have confirmed that they wouldn't
give people direct help on their
mortgages either they would Levy a
higher wind for tax on oil and gas
companies to help people they say with
their bills not entirely clear how that
would work but help is not coming and it
is really a ticking time bomb and the
government are acutely aware of this
some people have come off in two-year
deals this year but a lot more people
are coming off them next year two and a
half million people in an election year
people may well lose their homes if they
can't make these payments and it looks
like interest rates are not just going
to go up this Thursday but some
predictions are they could keep on going
up and up so a very anxious time and no
help immediately on the horizon